the deputy FBI director resigns
President Trump gives his State of the
Union address tonight oh happy happy hey
and we'll talk about the release of the
memo and the Kraken I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
lots of news to get to you today I will
also have some thoughts on Black Panther
I haven't seen it yet but I just have a
feeling that it will be the greatest
movie ever and that critics will love it
more than any movie has ever been loved
by anyone at any time at any place in
history I think it's just gonna be that
good or maybe it won't and we'll never
find out about it that's possible as
well we'll talk about a lot of that sort
of stuff in deconstructing the culture a
little bit later in the show
but before we get to any of the myriad
topics upon which we must have fine
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at policy genius so every
year 30% of people make a resolution to
be more financially responsible and then
those people don't do anything well
don't be one of those people make that
resolution and then go out and make sure
that you are covered for life insurance
because here's the fact if you plotz
tomorrow your family is going to be
without money okay that is not
responsible planning you want to make
sure that your family is fine if you
plot to mean aside from the emotional
loss of you plotting they shouldn't have
to deal with the financial fallout and
that's why you need to go over to my
friends over a policy genius it's the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance online they let you compare
quotes in just five minutes
and they don't just insure life they
insure everything they compare health
insurance disability insurance pet
insurance renters insurance
there are lots of ways to be responsible
and policy genius allows you to do that
at the most effective possible price so
if you made a new year's resolution to
be more financially responsible do it
right now like really right now just
pause the podcast go over to policy
genius and then get your life insurance
and then when you come back and you're
shocked by the news and have a heart
attack no one will care because your
family will be paid it'll be fine okay
so policy gene is calm it's the easy way
to compare and buy life insurance again
it's free policy genius get your new
year's resolution resolved in five
minutes over at policy genius.com
all right so we begin today with the
firing or else ting of Andrew McCain so
there was a lot of talk over the last
year and a half about Andrew McCabe
Andrew McCabe was the deputy FBI
director he worked under FBI director
James Comey and then for a short period
of time he was the interim FBI director
before Christopher Rea was appointed to
head that to head that organization well
yesterday Andrew McCabe finally stepped
down from his position it was unclear is
a lot of talk about whether he was
ousted or whether he stepped down
voluntarily
whether he had been basically told that
it's gonna be your brains your signature
on this piece of paper or whether he
just decided I've had enough of
president Trump making fun of me and I'm
leaving so here is what I believe it's
guy Benson over
at over at townhall right he says as you
already know FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe against whom the president has
fulminated in tweets is no longer
occupying his position
CNN's Jim Acosta reported the departure
was mutual and done on McCain's terms
but a lot of other networks are now
confirming that McCabe had been ousted
so why did that happen well there are a
few different explanations first off and
the mccabe just he's a month and a half
away from his announced retirement and
he decided that he had enough accrued
time off to leave so that's that's
possibility number one possibility
number two is that there's an IG report
an inspector general report on the
Justice Department's handling of the of
the Hillary Clinton email probe and that
there's a bunch of stuff in there that
makes Andrew McKay but look really bad
so there's a fox producer who Prieta
quote breaking McCabe out at FBI source
familiar says that in advance of the IG
report McCabe was told to begin what is
referred to as a terminal leave so
basically there's a bunch of bad news
those him come out about Andrew McCabe
and how corrupt he was and so he got out
now now this is a possibility remember
Andrew McCabe's wife and was running for
a state Senate seat in Virginia and the
Clinton connected governor of Virginia
Terry McAuliffe had a political action
committee and that political action
committee directed something like
$700,000 to McCabe's wife so that's a
pretty good indicator of where mchavez
politically because very rare that you
have a political mixed marriage and
there's a lot of talk inside the FBI as
well that McCabe should have stepped
aside in the middle of the Hilary email
investigation he did not he waited until
a full week only a week before this all
happened before before the election
happened and then he stepped down and so
there was talk inside the FBI it was in
texts that have now been uncovered and
in which was pretty clear that
higher-ups at the FBI could not
understand why McCabe had not stepped
away from the Clinton investigation okay
another possibility is that the FBI
director Christopher Rae has now read
the infamous Russia memo compiled by the
House Intelligence Committee of
Republicans that committee is voting and
they voted yesterday to release the memo
so it's possible whether Chris Rea over
at the FBI saw something in the House
Intelligence memo that said to him that
the cable is guilty of something and so
he went to McCabe and said listen you
need to step down you need to step down
so it's possible that there's something
about McCabe in there and there are
people have been leaking about what
exactly is in this memo president Trump
will discuss the memo in just a few
minutes here President Trump it's now on
his desk for consideration whether he
wants to release this
intelligence committee memo that
supposedly details all sorts of
intelligence committee misbehavior and
and bad behavior and Trump can release
that but a lot of the details have
started leaking out
well according to guy Benson elements
have started leaking including that
Trump appointed Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein approved an extension of
surveillance on former Trump campaign
aide Carter page who had been suspected
of malfeasance visiter the Russians now
it is quite possible that Carter page
was being surveilled for good reason the
guy was basically running around Russia
asking for someone to pay him allegedly
and Paige was reportedly under file of
FISA surveillance back in 2014 but it's
a possibility that McCabe was involved
in the in the get Carter page routine
because Carter page was a trump staffer
so we'll have to we'll have to find out
the New York Times is reporting by the
way that the FBI director Christopher
Rae found something concerning in the IG
report and he was gonna move McCabe into
another job which was effectively a
demotion instead McCabe decided to leave
the FBI so looks like it has nothing to
do with the House Intelligence memo
although we won't know until the House
Intelligence memo has actually been
revealed bottom line is that McCabe it
sounds like left for a good reason it
doesn't sound like this was Trump firing
Andrew McCabe why would he bother firing
Andrew McCabe a month before became is
gonna leave anyway a lot of people I'm
left saying oh this is obstruction of
justice so it's it's a slow motion
Saturday night massacre Chris Matthew
always a shame he came and he said you
know what
this is like Nixon you know he leaves
this McCabe guy he was protecting us
he's gonna stand up to Trump Russia
collusion Putin I roll out of bed coming
with a show coming here talk about
Russia
slow-motion Saturday mask ago I said
earlier today that make that Andrew
McCabe should not be replaced with
somebody who's just a presidential
stooge and who's going to help kill this
investigation because there are already
plenty of people around here quite
honestly who are just doing the bidding
of the president over conducting a
thorough and fair investigation it looks
like your Congressman I mean you're
young too young to have seen it but it
looks like a slow-motion Saturday night
Massacre one by one
Comey McCabe and now Rosen Stein and
targets in the target zone no you're
right look I was born shortly before
the president resigned in 1974 and there
are a lot of comparisons and parallels
to the Nixon years except at that time
you actually had a congress of a
different party that was a kind of check
on the president doing a thorough
investigation here there's a real
question whether that's going on okay so
that obviously is not the case okay the
idea this is a Saturday night Massacre
Saturday massacre if you recall back to
1974 is when there's a special in
council investigation into Nick into
Watergate and Richard Nixon ordered
Archibald Cox who was then the Attorney
General - he ordered Archibald Cox was
the special prosecutor and he ordered
the Attorney General to fire the special
prosecutor the Attorney General refused
and then he fired the Attorney General
and the special prosecutor by appointing
a new attorney general who would fire
the special prosecutor that's what the
Saturday massacre was McCabe was not
fired here really he was told by the
head of the FBI there's some bad stuff
about you and then he resigned he's
keeping his pension he's gonna fill out
his term okay no one has been fired here
except for James Comey and Comey of
course goes out and tweets
self-righteously
and what's amazing is that people are
treating James Comey as though he's some
sort of great Halcyon of truth right I
was open to the idea that James Comey
was a truth teller because his
reputation was pretty good before the
last year and a half but now all James
Comey does on Twitter is literally quote
himself he would really did this the
other day he actually quoted himself and
then he wrote this quote then he said me
right actually attributed it to me okay
James Comey is the most self-serving
some guy in American politics in a
position where he ought not be
self-serving you know President Trump
was not wrong to call him a grandstander
because pretty clear that's what's
happening here so Comey who's now on
Twitter he says special agent Andrew
McCabe stood tall over the last eight
months when small people were trying to
tear down an institution we all depend
on he served with distinction for two
decades I wish Andy well I also wish
continued strength for the rest of the
FBI America needs you now listen I think
that America does need the FBI but James
Comey is largely responsible for tearing
down the credibility of the FBI
it was James Comey who's responsible for
using the FBI as a political tool to
protect President Obama and Hillary
Clinton now is that an excuse for
Republicans to be doing what they've
been doing about the FBI I I'm not sure
that it is we're gonna have to see the
contents of this much ballyhooed House
Intelligence memo and we're going to
talk about that in just a second but the
idea that James Comey has anything to
say here or that the FBI was squeaky
clean during the Hillary and
station or that Andrew McCabe shouldn't
have recused himself or the Comey gets
to stand there and talk about honesty
and the FBI after legitimately changing
the law on the fly in order to exonerate
Hillary Clinton and let Loretta Lynch
then the Attorney General of the United
States off the hook all of that is a
bunch of nonsense all that's a bunch of
nonsense so before everybody starts
going off on the old mccabe was fired
it's the Saturday night massacre no
that's not what's happening at all let's
look at the facts and then we can
analyze okay so we're gonna get into
memo fight 2018 it's the greatest MMA
bout of the century we'll get into that
in just one second but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
wing so if you're like me trying to
follow all of these scandals day by day
and you are trying to follow the
narrative and you think that you might
need a drink okay that's why you need to
go to my friends over at wing so what
wink is really great for is you're going
to a dinner party you don't know
anything about wine you want to bring
them out on the line that's just going
to astonish everyone and you don't know
a bottle of wine from dishwasher
detergent you just don't know anything
about wine well that's what tri wink is
for so you go to try wink calm slash
Bend and they have this great algorithm
where they ask you it's a pallet profile
quiz they ask you simple questions you
know that people would never be able to
translate into a wine recommendation
like how do you like your coffee how do
you feel about blueberries and then they
send a wine that is curated to your
taste the more wines you rate the more
personalized your monthly selection each
month there are fantastic new wines
people at our office love length day we
had a wine-tasting party here at the
office and people got smashed because
that's what they do on a regular day but
here they actually enjoyed the liquor
they weren't just drinking turpentine go
to try winked calm /bin it's try winked
calm /span you get $20 off your first
shipment that's t ry winc calm / been
for 20 bucks off try wink calm / Ben
check it out and again this is the best
way to to purchase wine not only for
yourself but also for those dinner
parties where you just don't know what
to bring try wink calm so that also
makes for a great gift for Valentine's
Day which is coming up very shortly here
so okay so meanwhile memo fight 2018
it's the the rumble in the jungle
it's the duel at the palace it's just
gonna be incredible memo fight which
sounds just about as boring as it is
that is all about this House
Intelligence memo so I looked it up last
night
Devin Nunez his name is pronounced Nunez
it's not pronounced Nunez it's happened
it's Newtons okay so just so it we're
clear
Devin Nunez is the head of the
intelligence committee and Devon Nunez
who's a Republican representative from
California put together to this House
Intelligence Committee memo it's a
four-page memo that supposedly lays out
all of the malfeasance pursued by the by
the intelligence community in the Trump
Russia collusion case and Hillary
Clinton case so as you recall there was
a big movement to release the memo so in
order to release the memo to the public
they would actually have to vote in the
House Intelligence Committee to release
it to the public then the President of
the United States has five days to look
at it and determine whether or not to
release it and whether it released the
memo or not Trump is looking at that
right now so yesterday the House
Intelligence Committee voted along party
lines to release the memo they also did
vote to make the the Democratic memo
Adam Schiff Democrat came out with a
second memo that was supposed to debunk
the Republican memo and it has to go
through a process first you actually
have to vote to release the memo to the
rest of the house then you have to vote
to release the memo more broadly they
did vote not to release it to the public
yesterday but they voted to release it
to the rest of the house so other people
can read it they really should vote to
release all of this stuff at 1:00 so
that we can see as much of it as
possible in the in the fastest possible
way we should also see the underlying
materials as much as long as those
underlying materials don't actually
endanger national security Adam Schiff
of course was very angry this house
intelligence memo was going to be
released to the public and he does have
a gift I mean the man has the ability to
look nonpartisan even when he's saying
deeply partisan things here is Adams
chef Adam Schiff his Democrat from
California we had votes today to
politicize the intelligence process to
prohibit the FBI and the Department of
Justice from expressing their concerns
to our committee and to the house and to
selectively released to the public
only the majority's distorted memo
without the full facts a very sad day I
think in the history of this committee
as I said to my committee colleagues
during this hearing sadly we can fully
expect that the president United States
will not put the national interest over
his own personal interest but it is a
sad day indeed when that is also true of
our own committee okay so basically
Democrats are making the claim that
Democrats are making the claim that the
FBI is squeaky clean and then any memo
that comes out that condemns the FBI is
an attack on the FBI now I don't know
it's in the memo again you don't know
what's in the memo yet no one knows
what's in the memo
yet I suspect that there is some stuff
in there that's pretty damning of the
FBI and I also suspect that Republicans
are out over their skis on this memo
that they're over playing the memo that
they are suggesting that the memo is
going to be the kill shot that takes
down the Mueller investigation if so I
don't know why I think these are two
separate issues it is quite possible
that the FISA warrant on Carter page was
originally badly gotten there's more to
the investigation it's also possible
that the FBI was badly compromised in
the Hillary Clinton investigation but
was not super compromised in the Trump
Russia collusion investigation remember
and one of the weird oddities about all
this is we're talking about the
corruption of the FBI on behalf of
Hillary Clinton in the last election
cycle but it was the FBI's constant
intervention who's James commis
intervention the non intervention that
intervention and non intervention that
probably tossed the election away from
Hillary Clinton's you Donald Trump
meanwhile we didn't hear anything from
the FBI for months about the Trump
Russia collusion investigation that was
going on so there's a lot of oddity
about all of this Democrats I think our
our posturing you know if they suggest
that the FBI is completely clean that
the memo is completely made-up and it's
all nonsense and we just want to protect
the FBI and national security the
Democrats have spent my entire lifetime
attacking the FBI and national security
so I find this a little bit convenient
politically Nancy Pelosi is doing the
same thing she says that she's deeply
deeply angry over the Devin Nunez memo
this is a very big honor that the leader
gives to the ranking member that the
speaker gives to the chairman to be
deputized to protect the intelligence
intelligence to for force protection of
our troops for fighting terrorism and
the rest of that instead chairman Nunez
has act like a stooge acting with the
speaker stooge a stooge of the White
House at the acquiescence or at least or
maybe the guidance of the Speaker of the
House this is not about one thing or not
this is about the integrity and the
safety and our national security that's
what he says too that they have crossed
they have crossed from dangerously and
recklessly dealing with intelligence to
a cover-up of an investigation that they
don't want the American people to see
okay and this is this is where I say
that Nancy Pelosi and the Democrats have
gone off the rails okay where's the
cover-up
there's no cover-up okay the Muller
investigation is proceeding apace the
the noonas memo doesn't have any
you can do it the Miller investigation I
think we need to separate out all these
strands right now it feels like we're
just in a chaotic wind storm of scandal
and innuendo but when you separate out
all the strands what you find is many
things can be true once as I said last
week it is true that the FBI was
compromised badly compromised in the
Hillary investigation it is also true
that it's possible that they were
compromised at the beginning of the
Trump investigation but not later we
don't know yet it's possible the House
Intelligence memo is an effort to try
and get the Muller investigation by
essentially stepping on the FBI that's
possible I don't know I haven't seen the
memo what I will say is that I think
both sides are deeply overplaying this
so the Democrats are saying the memo is
like when they act this scared by the
way it makes it look as though the memo
actually has something damaging to say
when they act as though that what what
the Democrats really should be saying is
I don't know everyone's going so crazy
about this memo
it's a biased political document that
obviously is an attempt to overturn the
the Muller investigation or to throw mud
on the on the on the skirt of the Muller
investigation but I don't know why
everybody so hot and bothered about it
if it should be relatively easy to bunk
if you're a Democrat or they should be
able to just say this isn't true this
isn't true this isn't true or you're
drawing the wrong conclusions from a set
of fact so the Democrats instead are
going crazy oh the memos the worst thing
that ever happened the memo is an
attempt to obstruct justice nonsense
nonsense meanwhile on the right you got
a bunch of people who are saying the
memo is the end of the story the memo is
just this thing is just so important
this memo which was indeed composed by a
partisan group in the House Intelligence
Committee and this memo is going to be
the be-all end-all yes it's the usual
suspects were saying this is sean
hannity over on fox news he says the
noonas memo is huge its enormous it's
gigantic talking with Jeanine Pirro
because this is not a game we are
talking about people's lives we're
talking about potential crimes we're
talking about people being charged going
to jail but more importantly and the
scary part of this and I'll throw this
to Sarah for more information is that we
have now weaponized the powerful tools
of intelligence FISA is important
because we that means that's our
government spying on citizens and if
Hillary's bought and paid for dossier
was the foundation to do this Wow it was
a very shoddy Foundation influenced a
presidential election only elected
President of the United States voted for
by the people of this country Sean this
is bigger than any
anybody can imagine that this makes
Watergate like stealing a Snickers bar
absolutely and think about okay well
nobody's seen the memo stop setup
nobody's seen the memo okay no one's
seen it it's bigger than Watergate it
makes Watergate look like stealing a
Snickers bar we don't know what's in the
memo yet so can we all just calm down
and wait to see what's in the memo can
wait to see the underlying documents
right the DOJ is claiming that Devin
Nunez wrote this memo without actually
seeing the underlying intelligence also
I thought that actually rare point where
I'm gonna watch this I'm gonna give some
credit to slate okay for all you folks
who don't think that I read bipartisan
sources okay slate had an article about
this and they made what I thought was
actually a relatively decent point what
they said was the Devin the Republicans
are fulminating over FISA warrants being
issued against Carter page suggesting
that the FISA courts are so shoddy that
they issued a bad warrant against Carter
page in an attempt to get trumped they
went right along with the FBI they just
rubber-stamp whatever comes in front of
them and yet the same Republicans who
are suggesting that the FISA system is
so deeply compromised that it was
allowed to to almost subvert the will of
the people in an election those same
people voted like two weeks ago to
extend FISA authority under section 702
for another six years without amendment
right the same people who are
complaining the FISA process is too
deeply compromised to allow the American
people to feel safe where for extending
Pfizer's Authority so it sounds a little
bit hypocritical I think it's not a
terrible argument Seb Korca does the
same thing on Fox News last night he
says the Nunez memo is a hundred times
bigger though I mean you talk about
hyperbole just watch this hyperbole this
is this is crazy hyperbole I don't want
to spoil it get you guys I don't want to
spoil the punchline here here's Seb
Korca former Trump administration staff
are suggesting how big the Nunez memo is
but now the evidence has been mounting
and mounting and mounting and one
smoking gun after another it's
incontrovertible at this point it is but
it has to be put in the context of the
history of our great nation remember why
was America created it was created
because of the usurpation of power the
capricious usurpation by a leader
thousands of miles away that's why
America was created it was about tea
tanks it was about stationing troops on
private property without permission this
this is a hundred times bigger this is
our government spying on political ad
the
Cirie's this is federal law enforcement
officials obstructing justice okay it's
the way it is it's a hundred times worse
than the American Revolution the British
literally put British troops in people's
private homes okay see the memo yet you
haven't seen the memo yet so this is why
I think that when Republicans overplay
their hand it makes them look bad when
people like me are saying guys calm down
why don't just wait to see can we just
wait and see
then maybe you should wait and see okay
I am fully open to the idea that the FBI
acted badly here the FBI acted in
criminal fashion I'm fully open to that
idea I'm also open to the idea
Republicans aren't wildly blowing this
out of proportion for political purposes
but it seems like nobody from either
side is willing to acknowledge the
obvious no one knows what's in the memo
outside of Congress no one knows what's
in the underlying intelligence outside
of the DOJ and the FBI so before we all
get on our horses and ride to our
battlements perhaps we got to look at
the underlying information okay in just
a second
I'm going to talk about Democrats who
continue to push radicalism on a regular
basis in Congress it is pretty
astonishing it's the one thing that's
holding up Republicans I think in some
of the in some of the polls first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
Skillshare so it's January it means that
a lot of you are think about your new
year's resolution well one of your new
year's resolutions if it's not should
have been to increase your skill set
right the fact is that you can't expect
to stay at a job for 30 years anymore
since since I left law school I've
worked at five or six different jobs
increasing my salary each time and
that's because one of the things I'm
committed to is constantly broadening
and enriching my skill set one of the
ways I do that is by using skill share
it's an online learning platform with
over 18,000 classes in design business
technology and more it's one of the ways
that you can make sure that your resume
is constantly growing constantly updated
constantly making you more money I've
taken some classes on social media
marketing we've taken class on an SEO
here at the Daily wire and right in time
for the New Year Skillshare is offering
my listeners a limited time offer of
three months of Skillshare for just 99
cents that's three months of Skillshare
for just 99 cents to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro 99 again
go to Skillshare comm slash Shapiro 99
you get three months of skilled chef for
just 99 cents spectacular deal act now
for that special New Year's offers start
learning today Skillshare comm slash
Shapiro 99 you get three months of
Skillshare for just at nine
nine cents go check it out it's pretty
awesome okay so meanwhile Democrats
continue to demonstrate just how radical
they are one of the reasons that the
House races are still competitive is
because despite all of the chaos
surrounding the Trump administration the
Democrats still continue to push some of
the most radical policies and rhetoric
that I've ever seen in in modern
American history Kirsten Gillibrand for
example just makes it fool of herself
yesterday she's talking on the view I'm
still waiting for my invite guys
I was promised that you were going to
consider bringing me on the view because
this would be a highlight of my life but
apparently you'll have Kirsten
Gillibrand who'll just go on there and
lie to you openly repeatedly she says
that chain migration on illegal
immigration chain migration is a racist
slur this is the new democratic talking
point that makes literally no sense
since chain migration has nothing to do
with slavery and was a term that has
been used in legal circles for literally
decades
here's Kirsten Gillibrand suggesting
that when you say chain migration
meaning like I come in and then my
parents come in and my cousins come in
like a chain like a daisy chain hmm not
like chains of slaves Connie people are
so stupid here she says it's a racial
slur do you agree with Nancy Pelosi when
she says he wants to make America white
again and that's what this is about I
think a lot of President Trump's
rhetoric is racist and let's be very
clear
[Applause]
change migration when someone uses the
phrase change migration it is
intentional and trying to demonize
families literally trying to demonize
families and make it a racist slur it is
not right and so we have to change the
debate these are people these are
families and as elected leaders I mean
the way I look at it I'm gonna fight for
your child and these children as much as
I'm gonna fight for my own and that is
our job as elected leaders to fight for
these kids you gotta fight for the kids
don't you understand we gotta fight for
the kids yesterday the Democrats
including Kirsten Gillibrand voted down
a bill that would have prevented
abortion except in cases where the
mother of the life the mother is in
danger it would prevent an abortion
after 20 weeks 20 weeks okay that's not
an extreme position here is the fact
about a 20 week old baby in the womb
that is a full baby okay there are
babies who are now living outside the
womb at 20 weeks outside the womb if you
see an ultrasound should an ultrasound
like last week I think of what a 20 week
old baby looks like in the womb it is a
fully formed human child okay there's a
reason why if you look over to Europe
and so funny the left is constantly
talking about the wonders and glories of
Europe Europe is just this tremendous
wonderful rich place of culture and
happiness and open marriages it's just
so they're so progressive over in Europe
why can't we just be progressive like
the Europeans here are the abortion on
demand laws in various European
countries Greece illegal past 12 weeks
Austria illegal past 12 weeks
Germany illegal past 12 weeks France
illegal past 12 weeks Italy illegal past
12 weeks
Spain illegal past 14 weeks South Korea
abortion on demand is illegal totally
Ireland illegal Poland illegal Sweden 18
weeks
Norway 12 weeks denmark 12 weeks and
said thanks to James Hansen and
contribute to the Federalist okay the
idea that that Democrats are somehow in
the mainstream when they vote down a
bill overwhelmingly right they vote and
they vote in favor of killing babies
after 20 weeks that's an extreme
position and then they talk about how
they want to protect all children like
their their own children it's just sick
ok science does not support this science
actively opposes this where at least the
facts would if we had any moral sense
whatsoever but they're so extreme that
at the same time they're talking about
how a migration is a racist term I'm
talking about how Trump wants to make
America white again by admitting 1.8
million illegal immigrants in another
or million legal immigrants through
chain migration there they're saying
that they're not extreme over over the
issue of abortion by the way the
headlines on this has been ridiculous
says Senate votes down from proposal to
ban abortion after 20 weeks the Senate
didn't vote down anything the bill would
have passed 51 votes it had 51 only two
Republicans voted against it a couple of
Democrats voted for it okay the fact is
it would have passed except the
Democrats filibustered it so they
actually use their filibuster power to
ensure that women can still murder
babies at 21 weeks in the womb so very
exciting stuff from Democrats that's not
their only extremism Nancy Pelosi
continues to suggest that tax cuts are a
dark cloud this is the language that she
used you know it's funny I remember not
so long ago when there was a rich
Republican was if we used the term dark
or said that it was it was a black
period for the United States and people
suggested that that was racist when
Nancy Pelosi says the tax cuts are a
dark cloud says the tax bill is really
the dark cloud that hangs over the
Capitol really you know the tax bill
that's been boosting the stock market
and causing people to get raises that
tax bill the one that you called crumbs
that's being put in that's putting
thousands of dollars back in Americans
pockets that tax bill she says they sell
it as middle-class tax cuts but 86
million American middle-class families
will be paying more in taxes as a result
of this bill that is untrue as
fundamentally untrue okay there's no
data to support that the vast majority
of American taxpayers will be receiving
a tax cut I'm one of the only people in
America who won't be receiving a tax cut
under this bill because I live in a
stupid state called California yeah but
she says this is what keeps her up at
night is that is the tax cut so they're
they're against tax cut so here's what
we know about the Democrats they're
against tax cuts they're against
limitations on migration because that
would be racist any limitations on
migration by the way would be racist
apparently and they're in favor of
people killing babies at 21 weeks so but
they're not extreme at all they're not
extreme at all the people are really
extreme are the Republicans james
Clyburn over at the Congressional Black
Caucus he says that right now the
America we're living in is like Germany
circa 1934 by the way Germany circa 1940
and 34 for the historically
illiterate was the year after Hitler
took power it was during the night of
the Long Knives when Hitler literally
sent his minions out to murder all of
his political opposition's and
consolidated all power in 1933 under the
enabling act which basically made him a
dictator and james Clyburn says that's
the United States right now which makes
perfect sense because james Clyburn
right after this was stabbed to death by
the Trump administration except for not
hears james Clyburn i can only equate
one period of time with what we
experienced him now and that was what
was going on in Germany around 1934
right after the 1932 elections when
Adolf Hitler was elected Chancellor he
began to do things to discredit the
media to disrupt the judicial system and
if you recall from your studies
they had swastikas hung in churches all
over Germany it's just like that right
because people have Trump flags hung in
churches all over the United States
forcibly okay it's just like 1934
Germany
that's how radical the Democrats think
the situation is but they're the ones
who are actually radical one of the
things that's amazing is how the media
have covered for Democrats so back in
2005 I mentioned this briefly on the
show the other day back in 2005 there
was a photo that was taken of Barack
Obama and other members of the
Congressional Black Caucus of Lewis
Farrakhan booth Farrakhan is an open
anti-semite he is a brutal vicious
racist anti-semite he's a piece of
garbage Lewis Farrakhan whose Farrakhan
head of the Nation of Islam and he was a
he was visited he visited an event
hosted by the Congressional Black Caucus
right he he he used to hang out with
keith ellison the the chem the guy who
campaigned for DNC chair he was the
backer of the Million Man March he he
openly campaigned against particular
opponents of Barack Obama's you know the
fact that lose Farrakhan was
photographed among all these Democrats
in 2005 and no one seems to care it's
amazing imagine if Republicans House
Republicans had had a meeting in 2005
with David Duke that's the equivalent
here the media covered all that up the
media covered all that up and then james
Clyburn says that this is like 1934
germany if it's like 1934 germany that's
only in that the media are willing to
overlook certain political proclivities
on behalf of a of a particular political
party but otherwise just just insipid
okay in just a second I want to talk a
little bit more about sexual harassment
me too because in the State of the Union
of course we'll get to that but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at tripping calm so tripping calm
is the best way to travel now let's talk
about
about this the other day my wife and I
recently in the last few years we've
started vacationing in condos when we go
to visit someplace we have a couple of
kids now and we need more space it's not
enough to stay in a hotel suite we also
need a kitchen because we keep kosher so
we would like to cook for ourselves well
that means that we have to get a place
that is not just a typical hotel room
and it turns out it's much nicer if you
have a lot more room to spread out it's
a home away from home well that's what
tripping comm is for that the world's
number one site for vacation rentals
they're trusted by millions of travelers
including the Shapiro family with
trippin comm onesearch lets you filter
compare sort over 10 million available
properties on trusted sites like VRBO
TripAdvisor booking calm and more enough
to wonder if you're getting the best
deal on that winter cabin or beachfront
home you'll save an average of 18% per
night by booking your vacation with
trippin comm so don't forget if you want
to save time and money while booking the
perfect vacation rental for your next
trip head to trippin comm slash Shapiro
today that's trippin comm slash Shapiro
again trippin comm slash up hero that
lets them know that we sent you also
it's just it's fantastic I'm telling you
you will enjoy your vacation more when
you have room to spread out
when you have a washing machine right
like basic necessities that you miss
when you're at a hotel it's it this is
what tripping comm is for and it is just
fantastic so check it out trippin comm
again that's trippin comm slash Shapiro
so go check it out and let them know
that we sent you okay so in just a
second we are going to talk about sexual
harassment as well as State of the Union
stuff because we have a lot coming up
tonight actually we are hosting a state
of the union party but for all of that
information you're gonna have to go over
to Daley wire comm so $9.99 a month gets
you subscription to daily wire calm when
you get that subscription you get the
rest of our show live you get the rest
of andrew kleavon's show live you get
the rest of Michael Mills god help us
his show live you get all of those plus
get to be part of our mailbag and if you
get the annual subscription then for $99
ear you get all of that stuff plus you
get this the greatest in all beverage
vessels left this tears hot or cold mug
now when you get this tumbler when you
get this tumbler I'm not saying that the
power of my intelligence has been
physically infused into the tumbler and
you will gain 10 IQ points I'm not
saying if that's what's going to happen
but if it did happen you shouldn't be
all that surprised because we have been
working on that process for quite a
while here at Daily wire offices frankly
that I'm refresh now I feel smarter
that's what this will do for you so
check that out also tonight the State of
the Union address we're doing something
I desperately don't want to do
a live stream the whole thing yeah the
president is gonna speak to the nation
in his second State of the Union dress
really is first technically and you
should watch us with us here at the
Daily wire starting at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
5:00 p.m. Pacific we will be hanging out
with you the entire interminable time
leading up to during after the address
it'll be absolutely terrible and we will
be there for every terrible moment of it
plus we will make fun of the Democrats
rebuttal
I mean I'll make fun of the whole thing
because I mean come on I hate the State
of Union dress it's so stupid so if
we're gonna have to suffer through it
suffer together with us enjoy the pain
live the suck it's gonna be awful be
there with us catch live streams of
Daily wire calm daily we're Facebook or
daily where are YouTube and you can
spend the evening with me with Andrew
clave with Michael Mills and with daily
where God can Jeremy boring and we will
comment on the address we're gonna mock
each other or we'll mock the government
will mock our political leaders will
mark our guests there will be a couple
of special guests who are dropping by so
check it out again that is today January
30th 5 p.m. Pacific I'm sacrificing for
you so dammit if you're not here on be
mad ok you better show up because I'm
gonna sit here and miss my evening with
my children to watch this garbage then
you better be there to suffer with me
come on misery loves company Facebook
and YouTube and you can get notified
when we go live if you subscribe over
its daily wire calm it's a party that
you don't want to miss ok check it out
or if you want to just listen the
podcast later iTunes SoundCloud all of
your usual podcast apps check that out
subscribe over YouTube we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
in the lead-up to the State of the Union
address the Democrats continue to talk
about sexual harassment and sexual abuse
and the me2 moment now the reason they
keep doing this is because they figure
the longer they keep this alive let's
say that in 2018 Democrats take the
house good shot that happens right
Rodney Frelinghuysen who is a
congressman from New Jersey in a real
battleground district he's the head of
the House Appropriations Committee he
said that he's not gonna run for
reelection the indicators if he had to
make a bet you'd lay about the
Republicans lose the house might be
closer than you think it'll be but
that's not a terrible bet at this point
so Democrats are hoping that in 2018
they take over the house and then they
initiate a series of investigations and
hearings about president Trump's
proclivity for sexual abuse and
harassment allegedly that's what they
want that's why they're keeping this
alive well yesterday kirsten gillibrand
who wants to run for president in 2020
and she's really just a week terrible
version of hillary clinton she's not as
good politically as hillary clinton
which is saying a lot she's a bad liar
which is which is a much worse liar than
hillary clinton which is saying a lot
she goes on the view again we're playing
all these clips from the view guys
where's my invite I ask you again come
on
okay so Joy Behar is asking is asking
Gillibrand about why she stood against
Al Franken she says well we have to put
partisanship aside and we really have to
stand up against sexual abuse in all
parties and that's when Meghan McCain
steps in no Meghan McCain it's really
fascinating because Meghan and I used to
be politically at odds I think she used
to be a little bit more left-wing and I
probably used to be a little bit more
abrasive believe it or not and and now I
I will say that Meghan is done a very
good job on the view of representing an
actual Republican position which is
something that he's been missing for a
long time watch as Meghan McCain with
two simple questions dismembers kirsten
gillibrand on screen it's amazing means
they're not difficult questions to
answer and they're not difficult
questions to ask but she has two simple
questions and she she turns Kristin
Gillibrand she reduces Kristen
Gillibrand to a pile of rubble with two
simple straightforward questions that is
our job our job is to speak out to say
no to President Trump to say it's not
okay we want accountability we want
transparency we want Congress
specifically Republican leaders to hold
the hearings and have that transparency
that we don't have today
because it is there's some inconvenient
truths on both sides reportedly Hillary
Clinton is under fire for covering up
for a top advisor who was accused of
sexual harassment back in 2007 she
docked his pay and made him seek
counseling but allowed him to stay on
and women claim his harassment continued
you are a longtime supporter of the
Clintons and consider her a bed tour do
you think her response this weekend was
appropriate well as you know I think
these things have to be dealt with
whether you're a Democrat whether you're
Republican you need transparency
accountability and no one is above
criticism but in that case I don't know
all the details
suddenly she suddenly she just is
reduced to a quivering mass of I don't
know and then Megan McCain follows up
and she a sir okay so you know you
campaigned with the Clintons do you
regret that and Kirsten Gillibrand again
has no answer because all of this is
partisan pandering it's obvious it's
partisan pandering and how is Hillary
Clinton not being raked over the coals
today it's insane Clinton's campaign
manager came out and she said listen I
wanted to get rid of this guy I wanted
to get rid of this guy inside Hillary
Clinton's campaign who is her faith
adviser burns stridor who was alleged to
have sexually harassed the help right
and and Hillary Clinton's campaign
manager in 2008 Patti Solis Doyle she
says that she objected to this guy being
on K on staff burns Strider and Hillary
personally overruled her so a young
woman made a complaint to our head of
operations about sexual harassment
against burn strikers just yes justice
O'Connor who is now the CEO of the DNC
against burn Strider who she reported to
the incident was brought to my attention
and you know I did my due diligence I
interviewed all the parties involved I
looked at the evidence I looked at some
emails that he had sent I had looked at
other documents and came to the
conclusion that there was sexual
harassment involved that the young woman
was very credible and my recommendation
to the senator
mr. Pires and I was overruled
she's issues directly overruled by
Hillary Clinton what about the meets you
moment what about Hillary and the glass
ceiling and standing up for women where
all the women who are
talking about this I'm glad this is on
CNN like I'm not gonna pretend that the
mainstream media hasn't covered it at
all but can you imagine can you imagine
the hubbub if somebody inside for
example the the Ted Cruz campaign his
cab one of the people inside the Cruz
campaign had been accused of sexual
harassment and Cruz had just gone well
no biggie I'll block the firing right
well we'd hear about is men evil men
scuzzy men terrible men but when Hillary
Clinton does it it's totally fine and
meanwhile the the weak-kneed nosov of
the of the of the left on these issues
is pretty astonishing to mark ruffalo
who is just a political leftist peroxo a
par excellence and he was speaking out
on am to diem which is I guess
BuzzFeed's new show and he says that you
know all men have to have to make a safe
space in our privilege see that's the
thing when it comes to so when it comes
to stopping sexual abuse and sexual
harassment it's really about men making
a safe space in our privilege I don't
even know what that means but apparently
you won't like Hulk when he's not angry
when you're privileged you have a voice
and right now men are privileged they
have a privilege over women you know
it's just the way it is and and so we
have to make a space inside of our
privilege for for for a safe space for
women to speak up and I and I and I hope
I'm hoping that more and more actors men
will do it but they are and there are
ones that do it's just it's just we need
more what the hell was he talking about
anybody nobody's talking about and the
idea that men are privileged over women
in American society is absurd okay it is
not true in the United States right now
there are many many laws in place to
protect women as well there should be
the idea that that Marco that this is
about men providing a safe space for
women guess what this is more about
women actually seizing the space for
themselves to tell their stories about
how they've been sexually abused and
harassed and good for them for doing
that but what's funny is that Ruffalo
won't be criticized for being
patriarchal even though what he's
actually saying here is kind of
patriarchal he's saying well if we just
back off we the men we have to allow
women to be free okay women are free
it's in free and equal country and women
have the ability to speak out and when
they do and they do so in productive
ways we should support them
we should also speak out when it turns
out the people like Hillary Clinton are
stomping on women who are complaining of
being a harassed okay so time for some
state of the union talk so tonight the
State of the Union the stupidest
institution in all of American politics
so let's be clear about this it says in
the Constitution that the presidents of
the United States when requested by
Congress shall give them big Druitt
shall give them an update on the State
of the Union okay what that originally
was is a letter so George Washington
used to send a letter to Congress James
Madison sent a letter to Congress Thomas
Jefferson sent a letter to Congress
Abraham Lincoln sent a letter to
Congress the idea of the State of the
Union as this gigantic publicized event
is actually a relatively modern
invention the idea that that we need all
this pomp and circumstance we need to
treat this as looks the Oscars of
politics it's all annoying and
irritating and stupid and now we're
gonna get all these celebrities who are
gonna show up to to do a counter State
of the Union address they're gonna do
their own State of the Union address the
Democrats I believe I'm providing five
councilors to the State of the Union
there's Joe Kennedy I believe Bernie's
doing one I think Maxine Waters is doing
one there will be a cavalcade of
stupidity and irresponsibility so
that'll be great
also as I say a bunch of celebrities are
doing their own so Michael Moore tweeted
out that he was going to that there's
going to be all of these people but this
is 16 there are gonna be a bunch of
celebrities who show up for this for
this event
now the people's State of the Union
right it's gonna be common Rufus
Wainwright Mark Ruffalo Wanda Sykes
Rosie Perez John Leguizamo Cynthia Nixon
Kathy Najimy leads annuals and more
because nothing says people's state of
the union like a bunch of Multi multi
millionaires who come out and talk about
politics
nothing says State of the Union like a
bunch of actors who haven't been
relevant in ten years except for Mark
Ruffalo but they show up and have lots
of money and talk about politics I
desperately want to hear Oh Wanda Sykes
has to say Kathy Najimy I mean I've just
been wondering what the star of in
search of dr. Seuss has to say about
politics I just don't know I mean I'm
really turned on by this it'll be it'll
be fantastic the State of the Union
address should not be publicly televised
Trump's you just write a letter to
Congress we can all get on with our
lives instead we will sit here and
suffer through it with you tonight I
hate it I think it's stupid I think
Democrats and Republicans who pretend to
like the president it's just it's all
pretending dumb the the routine that we
have now where we all bring our favorite
guests and then we snap them up in the
seats in there in the rafters and then
we say
ah look they're up in there there's poor
Jimmy but poor Jimmy's been given a tax
cut and now poor Jimmy is rich it's
boring it's trite it's stupid yuck
the dumbest one that I've seen about
this by the way is apparently there is
some democratic representative who
invited a local state Rep to show up and
the state rep apparently according to
Politico is literally going to stan is
going to sit there I guess it's Paul
Ryan's opponent so Paul Ryan's opponent
Democratic opponent is district is
supposed to show up to the State of the
Union address and according to Politico
this guy is literally going to sit there
for the entire speech and stare at Paul
Ryan like this is his plan is to stare
at Paul Ryan that's weird
that's weird also tonight's gonna be
really terrible because you know that
all of the pretend unity is going to is
going to just completely fall away the
Democrats are not going to cheer when
they say the presidents of the United
States Donald Trump they're all going to
sit there will be stony silence from
half the chamber and then every time
Trump does stuff I would not be
surprised if there's some audible boos I
wouldn't be surprised if there's a Joe
Wilson ulai moment the whole event is
insanely stupid but it is a good time to
evaluate whether this has been a great
year for conservatives so as I've said
before I like a lot of what President
Trump has done on policy I like the tax
cuts
I like his Middle East policy I like his
regulatory cuts I like a lot of the
things that I like his judicial pics
Mitch McConnell came out said this has
been the best year for conservatives in
the last thirty years that he's been in
Washington DC 2017 was the best year for
conservatives in the 30 years that I've
been here the best year on all fronts
and a lot of people are shocked because
we didn't know what we were getting with
Donald Trump he was doing fundraisers
for Chuck Schumer three or four years
ago but this has turned out to be a very
solid conservative right-of-center Pro
Business Administration and we're seeing
the results of it people who were
right-of-center
are very encouraged to see the results
of the great work that was accomplished
in 2017 okay so again this there's a
problem here okay so it is true that a
lot of the policy is good it is also
true that we have yet to see whether
this was the best year for conservatives
because you can't tell at the time you
can only tell in retrospect if it turns
out that Trump's toxicity is actually a
problem for the conservative agenda then
all of the victories I talked about and
celebrate all of the things that I like
about President Trump well actually
we're down against the agenda that I
care about which is why I begged
president Trump nearly every day to stop
being the character that he is being and
there's a story yesterday the President
Trump when when Andrew McCabe when he
fired James Comey that James Comey was
given a ride back on on the FBI planes
DC and Trump called up Andrew McCabe
then the deputy FBI chief and he said
why are you giving Comey a ride back I
fired him and then McCabe said well I
wanted to because I thought it was the
classic thing to do and then Trump said
to McCabe your wife's a loser right that
kind of stuff is not good for the
president to say so when we say that
it's been a great year for conservatism
I can say it's been a great year for
conservative policy that I can say
without any doubt and without any qualms
say it's been a great year for
conservatism though ignores the
conservatism is a little bit more than
just the policy it is also the attitude
of unifying America around a set of
principles and in that way it has not
been a good year for conservatives okay
time for some things I like and some
things that I hate and then we'll
deconstruct the culture briefly so
things that I like yesterday I
recommended a book on Bach today I'm
recommending some music by Bach of
course if you've never heard the BAS
Brandenburg Concertos you probably have
you just don't know they're called the
Brandenburg Concertos the oricon charity
the Brandenburg Concerto number one this
is all written about 1621 so this is
very early music from Bach and the fact
that and it is great it means Baroque
music it's all great to listen to it is
great morning music that's the nice
thing about Bach Bach you can listen to
it anytime of day I think is the most
listenable composer Beethoven you sort
of have to be in the right mood Mozart
you have to be in the right mood
Brahms you certainly have to be in the
right mood Bach you can basically listen
to it anytime because there's great
variety here's a little bit of a box
Brandenburg Concerto number one
[Music]
okay since glorious music byway I got
the date completely wrong here at 1721
not 1621 really 1621 so as I said before
you know I talked yesterday about Mozart
rediscovering Bach I said was like 150
or GAAP of course I screwed up the
century is about a 50-year gap okay time
for a couple of things that I hate all
right so thing that I hate number one
first of all Beyonce wore a dress to the
Grammys that was supposedly so glorious
everything about Beyonce is just
glorious she's just the most important
person that has ever been or ever was
before the show I was playing somebody
the SNL's get the Bajan C which is just
the best skit that SNL has ever done by
a long shot in which in which Andrew
Garfield plays a guy who says that he
does not appreciate every piece of music
that Beyonce's ever made and then an
agency literally comes to take him away
it's very funny but Beyonce's dress that
she wore was apparently inspired by
Black Panthers this would be the second
time that she's done something publicly
in homage to the Black Panthers the
Black Panthers of course were a violent
terrorist group and when I say a violent
terrorist group I mean they actually
killed people so David Horowitz my
former employer over to dip
Freedom Center he actually used to work
with the Black Panthers he was a
communist who worked with the Black
Panthers and he was working in San
Francisco and knew a woman murdered by
the Black Panthers here he is telling
the story and in December 1974 Betty
disappeared and by the time the police
fished her body out of San Francisco Bay
I knew the Panthers had killed there I
and I had been interviewed by the police
they explained to me lots of things very
difficult too high to dispose of a body
unless you have an organization and then
it's not so hard you have safe houses
and so when that happened I was
personally devastated okay and Horowitz
ended up leaving the leftist movement
because of the Black Panthers extremism
and terrorism and yet now Beyonce pays
homage to them and we're supposed to
pretend that she's some great racial
unifier that of course is silly okay so
you know we'll skip the other thing that
I hate even though is pretty great and
we will get to a quick deconstructing
the culture so one of the movies that
has actually been put up for Best
Picture is the movie get out it is
really well made
it's very funny it's very clever it's by
Jordan Peele the comedian Jordan Peele
here's a little bit of the preview then
I'll explain why
what this says about American culture
this movie you got your today sure you
have your theater yeah you have here at
Cosi close god
do they know I'm black should they you
might wanna you don't mom and dad my
black boyfriend will be coming up this
weekend I just don't want you to be
shocked but he's a Blackman I never see
you like this before brother beat family
take a road look go back all bougie bad
come back get your pants up to your
stomach
[Applause]
so you guys coming up in the city yeah
I'm just heading up for the weekend can
I see your license please
he wasn't driving I didn't ask who was
driving I asked to see his ID call me
Dean I agree my man so how long has this
been known on this thing
we hired Georgina and Walter to help
care for my parents and they died I
couldn't bear to let him go the movie is
the movies creepy it's also really funny
it's really well-made here's the problem
with the movie it is supremely racist is
the entire premise against spoiler alert
the entire premise of the film is that
this black guy has a white girlfriend
they go up and visit her white family up
in some rich liberal area and they're
all Obama voters but all of these black
people who are there are either staff or
helpers and they've legitimately been
soul sucked like legit they're their
life force has basically their bodies
have been taken over by white people and
they've been relegated to a small
portion of their own brain the dying
white people have now in been infused
into these black people's bodies and
their life force has been drained from
them they'd basically been enslaved the
entire idea is a Stepford Wives idea so
separate wives is an anti man film right
the entire film was about how
traditional American culture sucks women
dry and turns them into these these
replicants these these sort of weird
Android creatures right that's the
entire premise of Stepford Wives well
get out is the same thing except with
black people the idea being that black
people who associate with white people
are eventually drawn into white
lifestyles when they become they and
they become stereotypical white people
right that's the idea that essentially
white people want to enslave black
people and that the way that they
enslave black people is by offering them
nice houses and sex right so Allison
Williams who plays his girlfriend this
loving girlfriend this hot white chick
right she's he that he's and they have
lots of steamy sex in the film but what
she really wants out of him is to suck
him dry of his blackness that's the idea
of get out and the fact that liberal
critics love this is indicative of the
fact that they refuse to acknowledge
that there is a racist undertone to this
there is I'm sorry there is a there are
people like Andrew clipping into
security says it was really just making
fun of liberal white people it is not
making fun of liberal white people the
entire point of the film is that even
the most liberal white people even the
ones who will go out of their way to be
tolerant on race who go out of their way
to say that they voted for Obama twice
and would have voted a third time it's a
running joke in the movie even those
people are seriously racists who just
want to suck black people dry of their
culture and history a that sort of
concept to reverse the races and every
would have been would everybody would
understand the serious problem with the
racial politics in this movie
again doesn't mean it's not well made it
doesn't mean it's an Oscar frontrunner
because the more left you are and the
Oscars the better off that means this in
the shape of water at probably the -
Oscar frontrunner Dunkirk will not win
anything because it's not lefty enough
but know that going into the movie it's
amazing to me that people have been
willing to overlook this so I will say
what what is the unsayable I'll also let
you know if black panther is good by the
way black Pam the reason I bring that up
is because as I said at the beginning of
the show the critics are just over the
moon about Black Panthers number one I
don't like Marvel movies generally so I
think they're always wrong about Marvel
movies but second of all we'll have to
see if the movies actually good or if
it's getting the Wonder Woman effect
where it's not just the Wonder Woman is
good it's the greatest movie that's ever
been made it goes something like this
gone with the win and then Wonder
Woman's way up here above Gone with the
Wind and well we'll see if they do the
same thing with Black Panther I got to
admit I was not blown away by the
preview I may be the only person in
America who is not I think Mathis agrees
with me that the trailer is overrated
we'll see we'll see
but I may be the lone voice who's
allowed to say that Black Panther wasn't
as good as it it is it is cracked up if
it is good by the way I'll be really
happy and I'll be glad to recommend it
so we'll let you know
alrighty we'll be back here tomorrow
with a full recap of the very important
very fascinating State of the Union
address we'll be back here tomorrow
we'll discuss all of it I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis lover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018